Hello. Welcome.
It is
March 5th, 2026.
And we are live in active inference
model stream number 21.1
with Bella Candemir, who will be
presenting and discussing on
distributional active inference. We'll
have a presentation followed by a bit of
discussion. So, if you're watching live,
you can write questions in the live
chat.
Thank you for joining. To you for the
presentation.
>> Um thanks, Daniel, for the introduction.
So, um
the title of my talk is distributional
active inference.
I'm a machine learning researcher who is
active mainly
in doing like reinforcement learning
research from a probabilistic
perspective.
So, a fun fact is that So, if I'm to
give this presentation to a machine
learning expert, so none of the three
words you would see over here
uh
would be perceived in in their correct
meaning. Uh at least I trust that so the
active inference part is kind of
what you will kind of understand
correctly up front.
Okay. So, let's make a thought
experiment
to set the stage.
So, I'm sure quite many of the people in
the audience
know who Arthur Schopenhauer is. He is a
famous philosopher.
And he has a saying
um
which goes as follows. Like, one can
indeed do what he wants, but he cannot
want what he wants.
So, that's the
you know, direct translation of the
original text.
That's what he said
around like 150 years ago or closer to
200, maybe.
So,
that what he points to is you know, you
know, current lingo what the motor
cortex is doing and what basal ganglia
is doing. So, there are certain things
we cannot keep control on or we don't
feel like we're controlling.
But, the thought experiment is as
follows. So, what would happen if
Schopenhauer lived today? And um
you know, had access to all the recent
advances in both AI and machine
learning.
As I both AI and computer computation
neuroscience, sorry.
So, he would probably
append his saying in the following way.
So, one can indeed do what she wants,
probably what that's how he would frame
it.
And can also perceive what she wants.
Um it's you know, pointing to the
inside-out aspect of the brain.
Uh
but, she cannot want what she wants
as he said before, neither can she
perceive without predicting. So,
prediction is essential to perceive
stuff.
And actually, we have a world model that
kind of
on which we have a control on kind of
what to perceive.
So, let's now imagine it that that was
kind of a keynote speech he he he would
give in in NeurIPS.
So,
um
Why why why am I saying that? So,
nowadays
you know, machine learning especially
reinforcement learning and computational
neuroscience are in close touch.
Reinforcement learning has already has
always been kind of historically uh
keeping a strong eye on
computational neuroscience. And what I'm
doing
so, what I'm super interested in
nowadays is to kind of tap all the kind
of knowledge
computational neuroscientists are
developing on real
let's say biological brains and use them
in the machine learning framework as
well as we can.
So,
how would I I like
whole brain level cognition with my
limited neuroscience background
but a little stronger like machine
learning background.
So the brain has some functional areas
at least
broadly describable functional areas and
they are in a kind of information flow.
We have occipital cortex which where
kind of sensory sensory stimuli are
ending on. And so there is some
information flow from here and there and
there is kind of a central part of the
brain.
Where basal ganglia is located which is
so to speak orchestrating the other
parts.
And the big questions are
actually what kind of information is
flowing from one area to the other?
And what is actually the purpose of this
flow from let say mechanistic point of
view? So what kind of an energy function
is being minimized? We can call it a
Lyapunov function.
And actually what kind of equations can
we come up with to let say describe this
flow mechanically?
And
so how on earth probably the most
interesting one among the four to me.
How on earth
adaptive behaviors emerging out of this
complex flow of information?
And let's take a quick glimpse on what
kind of answers people have developed.
We started from the conceptual level
unconscious inference point of view put
out by like Helmholtz long years ago.
Stimuli are raw signals and perceptions
are
you know, they are describing how these
signals might be coming out with a sort
of like a generative model.
An inference scheme going on.
And predictive coding
you know, moves this conceptual
framework one level forward and it gives
kind of a mechanistic or more like an
algorithmic or kind of neural circuitry
based kind of description of this.
Stimuli are actually residuals and
perceptions are kind of made in such a
way that
you know, an error between the actual
stimuli and the predictive predicted
stimuli are
you know, is minimized.
So, we have a complementary aspect
complementary point of view like the
Bayesian brain
point of view which is
looking at the things from kind of
computational goggles instead of like
algorithmic goggles. It says like
stimuli stimuli are likelihoods and
perceptions are posterior beliefs.
Active inference eventually
to me like to my interpretation is kind
of putting together predictive coding
and Bayesian brain hypotheses in such a
way that actions are also kind of they
they come to the game. They
you know, as another like an additional
aspect
additional degrees of freedom let's say
the agent is using to improve its model
fit.
So,
um
let's kind of try to explain try to
formulate
the Bayesian predictive coding approach
staying as minimal as possible.
Um so, and you know, from a machine
learning standpoint at least let's say.
So, we have three groups of random
variables. We have X which is our like
raw stimulus signals.
Y and S are our latent variables. They
correspond to the perceptions
made
like resulting from these
like raw sensory inputs.
And we have two groups of latent
variables.
And one group Y corresponds to
the latent variables that are within the
scope of the affordances of the agent.
So, the agent can do something about
them let's say.
And
the remaining S are kind of outside the
scope. So, they are kind of random
variables
you know, representing
the outside world the agent does not
have a direct control on at least.
So,
then we can
just
let's say apply the product rule on this
joint distribution and we come up like X
given Y S as one distribution, let's
call it a kind of decoding likelihood
and we also have a prior distribution P0
on
the latent embeddings. And we can do the
standard like
variational inference machinery
in the same exact way as what's been
practiced by like variational
autoencoders or whatever else being used
in machine learning nowadays and you
come up with
the
equation you see in the middle.
The learning problem is to find
an approximate posterior PQ which
maximizes this evidence lower bound. I'm
aware that in
the active inference literature, it's
more common to
refer to this elbow term, let's say this
elbow
let's say objective function
as variational free energy. So, one is
the just negative of the other. So, just
I will stick to the elbow formulation
over here because I'm more used to it.
The most probably kind of an average
machine learner is also more used to it.
And here what we haven't chosen yet is
how to
you know, how to handle P sub zero over
here. So, what kind of a prior
distribution we are assuming?
So, there the predictive coding approach
is coming to play. So, we talk about the
probability density function F of this
distribution P0 or P sub zero
which is proportional to
a quantity you see on the right which is
the expectation of the elbow.
Where
so the elbow is calculated on W, the
world model, let's say the
generator process you see at the very
top of the slide, but the prior is
intervened by a posterior, so the PQ.
So, this posterior is whatever most
recent inference the
uh the agent was able to make on the on
the latent variables Y and S. You know,
this PQ replaces P0, so that's what this
do operator is telling us over here.
So, the do operator is also intervening
into the variable regarding the
affordances,
and this intervention kind of chooses
which
density we are assigning to which
um
let's say
um which value of the
latent variable Y
we are talking about, and then the agent
will choose its actions, as I will show
in the following slides, in such a way
that uh this prior is maximized.
So, we call it an instance of predictive
coding because the expectation over here
is taken with respect to
um
with respect to um a stimulus which is
actually created uh
from the world model of of the agent
itself.
Okay, so how does
uh active inference uh extend this
Bayesian predictive coding scheme?
So, we uh again uh let's go back to our
like world model point of view. So, the
agent has a world model W, it's a
particular distribution on the uh
the group of variables like XYZ,
and we can just use standard
um
uh let's say product rule, like standard
machinery of uh the probability theory
and
you know what then we come up with
the probability of X given Y comma Z Y
comma Y comma S
times the probability of Y comma S.
What active inference is doing to my
understanding is that so it kind of then
swaps the order of this decomposition
and it comes up with kind of an
equivalent way of applying the product
rule where we are isolating the
probability on the
Let's say the prior probability at least
on
the low stimuli and then it chooses it
desired state distribution to
to govern this probability on low
stimuli. What actually boils down to is
applying the do operator once more this
time on X.
You know and the do operator kind of
replaces this P tilde X over here by
whatever desired state distribution the
agent has.
Um
So here's an interesting fact. We have
already applied the do operator to
replace the prior by the posterior. Now
we are applying the do operator once
more to replace this whatever P tilde X
we have over here by the desired state
distribution. I will not show the
intermediate
you know derivation steps over here but
you can find it in
in our recent preprint with the same
title. You will find it on on archive if
you just search for it.
Actually we are
disconnecting the variables S and Y and
S from X.
This means we actually don't need to
infer the posterior of Y and S given X
which actually is
quite a lot pronounced in the active
inference literature as far as I see.
So, that kind of that was surprising
actually. We eventually implemented in
our experiments, the results of which
you will see later.
Um the original active inference version
just we have we just proceeded the math
a couple of steps further.
Like we didn't stop at like where active
inference brought us, but we just took a
couple of additional like deductive
steps without actually making any
assumptions. So, we came up with a loss
function which had like four or five
something number of terms. And my PhD
student was actually reporting to me
that two of these terms were canceling
each other.
So, we were kind of plotting both. One
is just the mirror of the other.
And we looked into the case a bit more
you know a bit more detail and we
realized that the reason is simply Y and
S and X are just becoming independent.
So, this means you're not really gaining
any additional information by
calculating this posterior over here.
So, with this simplification we have a
resulting prior
which is kind of a little bit simplified
prior as I see as I said.
It's kind of highlighted in blue.
Then
plugging this prior into the evidence
lower bound we have developed earlier,
we come up with a minimalistic let's say
active inference objective you see at
the very bottom of the slide.
So,
um
now let's kind of move one step further
and let's plug whatever we have
developed into
a Markov decision process
that's kind of the more interesting
setting where we are assuming kind of
some dynamics in which the agent is
living.
Uh
and this time kind of let's just um
you know allocate the tuple like S and S
prime for
like whatever we were using S before.
So, the like the the random variables
about which
we cannot do anything. We cannot change
the physics of the outside world, right?
And
so here kind of S prime
corresponds to the
future perceptions while S corresponds
to the current perception.
Then
when we do the decomposition, we have
you know,
we have
let's say joint distribution as you see
in the first equation over here. We have
a
we have a policy prior.
So that's the agent's current way of
behaving and we have an encoder which
projects us from the raw stimuli to
perceptions
and a latent state transition kernel.
The perceived state is moved forward in
time
so that the agent can do planning. And
there is a decoder which projects us
from this latent state back to the
the the space of
stimuli so that the agent can compare
what's perceived and what's predicted.
And
so we have taken another step here.
This time kind of we diverged a little
from
what one is used to see in the active
inference literature. We just tried to
kind of simplify the process a little
more by
kind of
incorporating some ideas developed in
the probabilistic state space modeling
literature.
So it is common practice over there to
come up with a variational approximate
distribution
or approximate posterior distribution
used in variational inference
where the latent state transition kernel
or any other component you want to have
like up to your choice can be directly
taken
from the the forward model. It is fine
as long as you keep some of the terms
you know, specific to to posterior
distribution. So the machinery would
still work. It boils down to integrating
out certain terms and doing inference on
some others. So, we chose to kind of use
the same state transition kernel for
both the forward model and the
approximate posterior. So, they will
cancel out each other while calculating
the elbow. Then, the elbow simplifies a
little further and we come up with the
final active inference elbow you see at
the very bottom.
And it has quite intuitive kind of three
components. The first is actually the
first on the right after the equation
after the equality signal, let us say.
So, is where the model is where the
agent is actually updating its world
model. So, it is
comparing the predicted future to the
realized future, let us say.
And the one in the middle is what the
agent is using to
adapt to the environment, meaning it is
kind of
updating whatever it can update
to kind of
increase
the reward it will collect or to kind of
increase its fit to the desired state
distribution.
To increase the probability that it will
end up with a kind of state
which is a preferred state for the
agent.
And the last term is the entropy of the
pulse distribution. It is a term we are
quite used to see seeing in
in reinforcement learning.
It is for instance the a term you see in
any maximum entropy reinforcement
learning instance like soft actor critic
and so on.
But, interestingly here, that term
appears
as a direct consequence of some
deductive steps steps we take on an
assumed model. So, it's not kind of put
over there as a design choice, but it is
kind of a direct consequence of where we
started and all the deductive steps we
have taken on top.
Now, um, so what shall we do with this
formulation of active inference? We our
goal is to kind of address a couple of
problems.
Uh, I'm really in love with active
inference theory.
Uh,
just
uh,
simply because I'm in love with that.
So, I
uh,
I'm doing my best to kind of find its
blind spots.
And um, I will make a hypothesis about
some potential blind spots. Um,
So, remember that um, if if there are
kind of neuroscientists in the room, I'm
sure there are some. Uh, you will know
it better than me that uh,
the like basal ganglia has a dual role.
So, there are two streams of information
coming into the basal ganglia that end
up at the same dopamine neurons. Uh, one
stream is the perceived reward, which
has an excitatory effect. And the other
is the predicted reward, which makes
kind of the inhibitory effect.
And because of like thanks to this
duality,
the uh, the brain can implement temporal
differences. And temporal differences
are quite essential for like long-term
planning.
Um, but when I look at the the math of
active inference, I'm not really maybe
it's my fault, I don't know. I'm not
really seeing
clearly where where kind of the temporal
differences
uh, come to play.
And um,
it I mean, because of this, because of
this missing link, so the theory
inevitably
uh, prescribes for control uh, what we
call uh, in like in control theory uh,
the method called model predictive
control. So, you uh, roll out in your
world model, and then you uh, like among
all possible roll outs, you choose the
one uh, you choose I mean, that's kind
of uh, ends up with kind of the maximum
reward, and the corresponding actions
are implemented afterwards.
But,
I'm also missing how choose the planning
horizon. Uh so, how long for how long an
agent would plan using like sticking to
the uh the missionaries suggested by
active inference.
Also, active inference assumes uh let's
say there is kind of a latent uh state
space. So, the
um the the the dynamics are modeled uh
at kind of an
a latent embedding, so to speak, not on
the space of the raw stimuli, but on a
kind of on the space of the perceptions.
Why is it useful?
So, we all have an intuitive answer for
this. Most probably, computational
neuroscience also or kind of plain
neuroscience also has an answer to this.
But, I want to see the math. So, can you
show an equation to me like why it
should work?
From pure physicist attitude, let's say.
Um I've not also seen that in the active
inference
formulas.
And uh why do we care about these uh
let's say blind spots?
Because suppose we want to extend active
inference to
uh the case where Bellman backups are
applied,
we are free to do whatever we want
because the theory is not limiting us.
Then, whatever we do will become like ad
hoc.
And uh then the same for latent uh like
learning latent embeddings, whatever we
do
uh is still okay.
And um
it has some detrimental consequences on
the uh on the application of the theory
to reinforcement learning.
So,
first is
you know, it is we are stuck in the
model-based reinforcement learning
realm. So, it is model-based
reinforcement learning is
sometimes very useful, but
honestly, it's quite expensive. Can we
really not do anything model-free with
active inference? That's the first
question, and that's kind of um the the
answer has been no until now because of
the problems I've shown above.
The second is um so, because kind of we
cannot take active inference outside its
context so much and whenever we take it
outside we are completely free to do
whatever we want, we always repeatedly
ended up with in the reinforcement
learning domain let's say
to an already known reinforcement
learning algorithm and we ended up using
active inference only to justify our
design choices.
Um my point is that maybe we can do
better than that and we can make a
genuine reinforcement learning algorithm
out of active inference.
What are our concrete objectives? We
want to incorporate temporal differences
into the theory.
This way the hope is that we can come
like make up agents that can plan for
like infinite horizons.
Um and we can still in that kind of in
the setting benefit from
all the nice properties of active
inference and that could maybe make like
reinforcement learning
um
kind of a better
um let's say problem space to be used by
like real-world applications.
So the other is
more it's more like a clarification,
more like kind of to enhance our
understanding when and why state
abstractions
work.
And the third is
you know, we have to do state
abstractions um
so that's what the human brain is also
doing. That's why we have concepts, we
have words and we have a notion like an
object and so on.
But state abstractions
you know, we we are interested in doing
like making abstractions to kind of
simplify the tasks, simplify like
control tasks. There will be some
information loss. It will create some
uncertainty. How will this uncertainty
be um you know, accounted for during
planning and if possible also exploited?
So our we expect that so and I'll let's
say an improvement we make on top of
active inference to give some at least
some answers to these three questions.
So, uh to put things into
um
like into the algorithmic framework and
then we will do some math on top of
that. Uh we have chosen
um
a meta reinforcement learning algorithm,
let's say, from which we can derive all
the other kind of individual
reinforcement learning algorithms.
Uh we chose like model-based policy
iteration. So, we started from policy
iteration and we extended it to its like
model-based counterpart. What does it
mean? So, in policy iteration, we have
two steps like policy evaluation and
policy improvement.
And in policy evaluation, so we apply a
Bellman backup.
Uh
so, we have a value function Q and we
pass it through kind of a Bellman
operator to move to the next time step
uh with an observed immediate reward and
we want kind of the current
uh like the prediction on uh
the value of the current state
versus the observed reward plus the
prediction of the next state should
match. So, that's what the what the
Bellman equation says.
Policy evaluation is taking care of kind
of uh
you know, um
minimizing the Bellman residual.
And the policy improvement takes
whatever value function the policy
evaluation step has calculated
uh to improve the policy.
So, we have like we added a model update
step
where the agent is observing what's
going on outside, kind of keeping track
of all this kind of uh raw stimulus raw
stimuli and uh learning a predictor for
future stimuli. That's kind of the
environment model it is learning,
basically. Um so, what would be useful
for us is to kind of extend the Bellman
operator, the standard Bellman operator,
to a shape where which state transition
kernel is assumed is specified. That's
what you see as a subscript nearby the T
in the operator.
And
um so, we are interested in
uh so,
you know,
let's say framing the problem as a
distribution reinforcement learning
problem
so that we can make use of the
uncertainty around the value function
caused by state abstractions and maybe
also other factors.
Um
while while not needing to kind of
develop uh
let's say a
a
like a world model, meaning so
bypassing, so I mean distribution
reinforcement learning helps us kind of
learn return distributions without
needing to learn a state transition
kernel.
So, what is distribution reinforcement
learning
in a nutshell?
So, in like standard reinforcement
learning, we are interested in learning
the value function. It is the expected
uh sum of discounted rewards starting
from a certain state and uh
a certain action and following a certain
fixed policy afterwards.
So, distribution reinforcement learning
is not satisfied by the expectation of
this quantity, but it aims to learn the
whole like return distribution.
So, what is the distribution around the
discounted sum of
rewards?
Um so,
let's call this random variable the
discounted sum of rewards
um Z pi for a certain policy pi.
Um
The Bellman equation will hold in the
space of like uh
distributions as well. And uh when we
take a close look at this Bellman
equation, it uh
corresponds to applying the return
distribution, like passing the return
distribution through like three stages.
One is shifting it, the other is like
rescaling it.
Shifting by the immediate reward,
rescaling by
uh
some discount factor.
These are simple operations, but what
comes next is a bit dirty. So, we need
to take the expectation of this random
variable with respect to the state
transition kernel.
Um the uh the effect of this expectation
part is that so even for like very very
simple MDPs, very simple dynamical
systems,
um it is very probable that the return
distribution will be multimodal.
Um so, the task is not as simple as
let's say learning not only the mean,
but also the kind of the variance of the
return distribution by some assumed
density like normal distribution or
something. Um
It's not It's typically not easy to
solve the problem that way. That's why
it's common practice to resort to like
distribution-agnostic techniques. The
most common one is like quantile
regression. So, that's what we will
build on as well.
Our idea, so I mean our goal is to
incorporate this distributional
reinforcement learning framework into
model-based policy iteration.
Um and later on show that actually what
what we end up with
after this incorporation
actually covers a problem space where
active inference is an instance.
So,
um I I'm afraid I will need to show some
uh
some
some equations.
So, um
we I was talking about the return
distribution, right? So, it is kind of
actually a distribution of
a random variable that's kind of the sum
of sub random variables that they kind
of returns at each time step
like reward a reward kind of observed at
each time step then sum together summed
up after having some discount factor.
So, we can actually decompose this
return distribution into two
um let's say quantities. One is what we
call a Marco process measure. It is the
base measure of the underlying Marco
process without giving any reference
to any rupee yet. That's how kind of the
let's say how likely and a trajectory
starting from now going until infinity
is within a certain Marco process.
So that that's what we call like a Marco
process measure.
And the other
is
um actually um
a functional. Let me just show it.
We call a push forward process
functional. So we take a function F and
we apply that function to every single
element of a trajectory that's going
until infinity.
The idea is to uh you know um
let's say formulate the return
distribution as a push forward of a
Marco process measure. And this push
forward is via a push forward process
functional.
So um
there we need to do kind of some measure
theory the details of which I will just
skip. Um
but
thanks to um
a theorem called like a Urysohn's
Tychonoff theorem um we are able to show
that such a measure well-defined
probability measure
exists and we can indeed
uh you know formulate the return
distribution as you see at the very
bottom as a process measure a
well-defined probability measure on
infinite long trajectories
trajectories of let's say stimuli
and um a return function.
And uh we have used this decomposition
to uh extend the well-known contraction
lemma of distribution reinforcement
learning.
Um so that lemma says
actually if we have
a certain probability measure
uh let's say Marco process measure the
one you see on the right side right hand
side of the inequality just nearby F
um um
and then just nearby F um
the the the first argument versus
another one. It's just another Markov
process measure. So, the difference
between the two is that they they use
different uh state transition kernels.
So, we push them forward both like both
forward uh through a
um it's a some functional F uh some push
forward process functional F
and then after once we apply
um the Bellman operator.
So, um
we can prove that this Bellman operator
will kind of make the distributions
we calculate by um you know, applying
Markov process measures. So, I applying
the same push forward functional on the
Markov process measures calculated based
on two different
um
state transition kernels.
Why do we care about this? It is the
essence that So, if we apply if we keep
applying the Bellman operator, meaning
if we allow the agent to plan until
uh
you know, an infinite infinitely far
away future
we are sure that
there will be kind of fixed point that
will come up. So, which we can just take
as our training objective.
What kind of key implications uh
does this lemma have?
So, there is a fixed point, of course.
We know it from Banach fixed point
theorem. So, there is a single um state
transition kernel.
Uh so, sorry. There is a single
probability distribution for which like
after all the push forwards and so on,
for which the Wasserstein distance
between the the push forward process
functional and push forward process
functional and the Bellman operator
will give us zero.
Um but the catch here is that actually
this
uh
fixed point can be satisfied by multiple
state transition kernels. So it is a
fixed point only
for the kind of push forward
distribution, but not for the state
transition kernel itself. So then we are
talking about the kind of an equivalence
class that will lead us to the same
conclusion then.
My
you know
My hypothesis is that that could be kind
of why
you know agents might be interested in
doing like state abstractions.
And distributional reinforcement
learning I would expect to
distributional reinforcement learning to
outperform model based reinforcement
learning in the cases where kind of
these
like the equivalence class that's
generated
you know by this by this push forward
scheme
is large enough
that we can learn kind of the push
forwarded version of the distribution
with kind of without requiring as much
data as we would need to
you know to to infer the state
transition kernel.
Because one is kind of however many
dimensions we have on the state space
it's kind of a regression problem on
that
you know that dimensionality versus
after the push forward we have a one
dimensional signal which is of course in
quite many cases much easier to
learn from finite observations.
Let's give a visual example.
So what you see on the top is
you know
a Markov decision process that's been
quite heavily studied by
by reinforcement learning theoreticians.
So the agent starts from
state S1 and its goal is to kind of
collect as much reward as possible. The
problem is that it doesn't need to do
anything. It doesn't need to take any
action or develop any policy to stay at
kind of uh
at the kind of starting state, and there
it will keep collecting some small
reward.
But, if it is patient enough to go
through a number of states without
observing any reward, it will reach a
state as six where the reward is like
200 times higher.
Um
So,
what about taking this river swim? So,
it's called kind of the a river swim um
you know, environment, because the agent
needs to keep
uh choosing action towards the right
to
uh you know, go towards the right, but
it doesn't need to do anything to go
left, because we assume that the kind of
the river is flowing towards left.
What if we take this
uh
this
let's say
uh dynamical system and put it to a
latent embedding,
and we assume kind of a two-dimensional
observation space.
And the projection from the
two-dimensional observation space to
this latent space, which is actually
running the dynamics,
uh can be simply done by kind of taking
the average of the coordinates.
Then, what happens is that so, multiple
um
you know, coordinates in the observation
space corre- start to correspond to the
same latent state. For instance, the the
ones like the uh the
uh cells you see marked as like zero on
the um on the leftmost
um
you know, uh heat map you see at the
bottom, corresponds to state as one.
Like
uh the states marked as one uh in the
same heat map correspond to state to S2,
and so on.
That's the case uh when river swim has
like length
uh length of four.
If we increase the horizon, what we will
observe is that so, the equalness
classes will start to get larger. So, if
we look at the far left for instance, so
and count like how many fours we see
over here. There's quite many, right?
So, I mean that's kind of actually how
um state abstractions should be helping
an agent. So, uh
you know, summarizing the observation
space
you know, creates the coolest
equivalence classes
uh in such a way that
the after that abstraction's done
whatever action you take it doesn't kind
of
um make a difference about your goal
regarding whether you are on the top
right corner of kind of the rightmost um
um heat map you see versus the bottom
left corner.
So, uh there is some kind of math
uh behind uh so the technique we
developed, but I will uh if fine, I will
just pass on pass over this part of it
quickly. We need to uh introduce some
like a notion of a kernel and a
composite kernel operator and define
their kind of define their Lipschitz
continuities.
And so, that's kind of a technical
necessity.
And uh we come up with
uh probably the main the most important
theorem of the paper.
Um a formulation that goes as follows.
Assume an agent that has an encoder uh
you know, noted over here by S and a
decoder noted over here by like PD.
Um and kind of it applies kind of some
push forward uh
you know, functional after what it could
be kind of any reward function you might
choose and the Bellman operator to
calculate like Bellman backups.
So, uh so this Bellman operator, so I
mean the the result of this contraction
uh will be modulated by kind of three
terms, whatever discount factor we have
and also the Lipschitz
Lipschitz constant of the applied
encoder and Lipschitz constant of the
applied decoder. So, it's it's not
surprising. It's intuitive, right? So,
but so the
the simple but important takeaway is
that so, if the encoder over here has
a small Lipschitz constant, then the
whole contraction modulus will reduce
and the agent will start to adapt
faster.
That kind of matches with what we have
observed over here. So, if the
equivalence classes are large, then the
Lipschitz constant
of the encoder
will be small, making the contraction
modulus of the whole
you know, distribution Bellman operator
small. That will end up with kind of
faster convergence. That's kind of how I
could explain the machinery of the state
abstraction state might be going on in
in some mammalian brain.
At least I think it it will it is useful
for like reinforcement learning.
So,
um
what should we do about
this theoretical result? Actually, it
has like algorithmic implications.
First, so we need to kind of
define an embedding space
on which kind of state after like
abstract states might live.
And so, we can just redefine our kind of
whole process as you see on the top like
the return
return functional
um g hash and the Markov process
uh
measure coming up towards where kind of
an encoder and decoder is applied.
So, we can just
you know, decompose the process from the
state transition kernel and the encoder
and all the rest
which will give us an encoding process
and the decoding process.
Encoding process will project us to kind
of a latent manifold of kind of an
infinite long uh trajectories of
perceptions, not observations this time,
not stimuli this time, but perceptions.
And the push forward process applied on
top of that later.
Or kind of a decoding process coming
afterwards where kind of the push
forward uh operator uh uh
you know, governing the return.
You know, where the reward is
implemented uh is placed.
So, we end up with I will just skip the
mathematical details. We end up with a
composite measure. So, the whole process
can be described as this horrible thing
you see on the bottom left, which can
all be re-expressed as kind of uh
product of two measures actually. One
measure takes kind of the the other as
kind of like a
We have one measure on the uh state
abstractions, and the other measure
takes these state abstractions
uh as given and conditions on it.
This implies um
kind of a policy evaluation objective.
Um so, which using the decomposition
I've developed uh above and uh using
some some tricks people have developed
earlier for a completely different
purpose to do kind of uh uh
like to develop autoencoders uh using
the Wasserstein distance.
So, it's kind of uh deep generative
networks research, nothing even related
to reinforcement learning.
We adopted some tricks from there, and
we came up with an upper bound
on uh
the uh the policy evaluation loss one
would normally
uh adopt to perform distribution
reinforcement learning.
And uh it kind of brought us kind of
after some simplifications
to an algorithm which we refer to as the
push forward policy iteration algorithm.
Long story short, it boils down to
performing uh um
um performing distribution reinforcement
learning on a latent embedding space.
So, we need to kind of learn an encoder
to move from the current state-action
pair
to a latent embedding that encodes kind
of the trajectory of perception starting
from now going until infinity.
Um so, and on this latent space,
whatever we know about distribution
reinforcement learning, we just
implement it.
That's kind of what push push forward
policy iteration is.
Now, we are back to active inference.
So, remember that we have developed
um an an elbow for active inference. So,
uh remarkably, so the encoder and uh the
state transition kernel always appear
side by side over there. So, we can just
integrate out both and come up with
something that kind of matches
one-to-one to uh
what you see, uh
which we calculated as kind of the final
step of the derivations we have made on
this policy evaluation objective. So, we
plug it directly there.
And uh we come up so, and we back our
claim that it is actually an active
inference instance by doing some further
math, which I will skip now. So, on the
left so, I'm talking about kind of the
equality, like the identity you see at
the at the bottom of the page. So, on
the left side, you see kind of um what
let's say active inference prescribes
us, and on the right side
uh so, um we have kind of an equivalent
um
you know, version of it, which kind of
bridges us to the push forward policy
iteration algorithm.
Then, uh so,
all kind of boils down to actually
performing distribution reinforcement
learning on a latent space as as far as
like as I described. For that, we need
to get back to the kind of machinery of
performing distribution reinforcement
learning. As I pointed out earlier, so
we need to do like quantile regression.
And quantile regression
so is just kind of
typically done by kind of deterministic
functional approximators that are
let's say predicting each quantile of a
distribution.
Then we need to kind of project from
that view, let's say transition
ourselves from that view to a maximum
likelihood estimation view so that kind
of we can define
let's say amortizable parameters. So the
equivalent point of view is like
asymmetric Laplace distribution. So
probably so the mean of this asymmetric
Laplace distribution is
the minimizer of the standard quantile
regression. And we amortize this mean
and we also incorporate a
a standard deviation.
So both are parameterized by the
state-action pair.
And we end up with
an algorithm which we refer to as
distributional active inference.
So it is like long story short, it is
performing distributional reinforcement
learning on a latent embedding space.
And we only learn an encoder, but we
don't need to actually learn a decoder
because intuitively it goes as follows.
After
projecting ourselves to the
space of like perceptions, we can apply
push forwards and we can just take the
following steps like analytically. Okay,
we we don't need to project ourselves
back to the space of
let's say perceptions because we know
how to calculate rewards on this latent
embedding. Let's then just calculate the
rewards on this latent embedding, go
until infinity, and do all the Bellman
backups required Bellman backups on that
route.
So
remember that I've shown kind of river
swim and latent river swim to you.
So my hypothesis is as follows. So if
really kind of active inference is
useful
uh kind of
like when there's need for like state
abstractions, then uh the distributional
version and if our algorithm is really
doing active inference, then it should
be useful when state abstractions are
useful.
And or or it should work well when the
state abstractions are useful and it
should
you know, maybe work on par, but not
necessarily better when state
abstractions don't do anything useful.
Uh in standard river swim,
you don't need to do any state
abstractions because the state space is
one-dimensional. So, there is no further
compression you can do about that.
Uh so, as you see,
distributional active inference you see
in in red
is performing similarly to its
distributional but non-active inference
counterpart, IQQL, implicit quantile
Q-learning.
And the model-based version, PSRL,
posterior sampling for reinforcement
learning, it's the gold standard in
in reinforcement learning theory.
It works a little better when the
problem is easy, when the horizon
increases,
it goes from like 4 to 10, the models
start to perform similarly.
But when there is a need, when it is
beneficial to
apply state abstractions, distributional
active inference already starts from a
very close position to model-based
reinforcement learning and it it it
exploits all these kind of equivalence
classes, progressively growing
equivalence classes,
which are actually the
primarily the model-based learning
algorithm, PSRL, because then it becomes
like progressively let's say
exponentially more data hungry,
while the the distributional version is
not. The distributional
active inference
algorithm stands and all the others kind
of don't perform as well.
Then we
want we tested our claims also on
deep reinforcement learning.
So, uh on like we tried to kind of
choose as difficult tasks as our
computational
capacities allowed us.
We
kind of
we addressed
soft robotics problems
by studying the Evogym
control suite. So, here the task is to
catch the
the box that's kind of falling down with
a robot whose body is deforming. That's
kind of much more difficult control
problem that is a deformable body.
And the one you see in the middle is
one of the most difficult
locomotion tasks in a DeepMind control
suite. It's kind of the proprioceptive
version of it. And we have also studied
visual control where the input
dimensionality is very large. It's kind
of raw pixels.
And in all these kind of three suites
and for each actually we didn't test our
algorithm on only these three
environments. They are only
representative environments. In total as
far as I remember we have tested our
algorithm on like 17 different
environments.
So,
in all the kind of
three
use cases we have observed distribution
active inference to either perform
similarly to the best performing model
and or
much better than them. On average our
algorithm
has has been working. I mean we observed
it to work better than
all the other algorithms we were able to
think of as like baselines worthwhile
comparing. For instance, in the MC
vision
we have observed that it was working
better than in quite many cases. It was
working better than the Dreamer version
three which is kind of the most powerful
model based reinforcement learning
algorithm at present.
I actually as far as I know there is
Dreamer version four now. Honestly, I
haven't checked that one, but it
shouldn't be very very old.
Uh
so, that's the standing.
So, we have a couple of
questions in mind now about like how to
progress from this point on.
The first is like what kind of finite
sample analysis we can do?
Um so, how many
let's say interactions we need to train
like distribution active inference?
Uh
you know, to a good level.
The other is what if our
reward function is composed of like sub
rewards? Can we just
you know, learn this composite reward
function kind of parametrically so that
at the test time we can decide which
point within the Pareto front we want to
stand?
Uh the third is like
can we reconstruct reinforcement
learning theory from measure theoretic
basics because currently it is
I think due to historical reasons, it is
developed on top of um
combinatorial optimization. Um and we
are sensing nowadays that kind of the
theory developed on top of it is kind of
a bit limiting us.
Can we just go back to the beginning and
just reconstruct all the system sticking
only to the kind of measure theory
measure theoretic principles?
Um and the fourth is
can we kind of learn foundation policies
from offline data
in such a way that
so at the test time by choosing any
reward function we want, we kind of in a
zero-shot manner read out
the optimal policy.
So, that's all I have. If there's been
anything you happen to like about the
things I have talked about,
um
the people besides the the guy on the
top left
deserve the main credits. Thank you very
much, and I'm happy to answer your
questions now.
>> Great. Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, those watching live can write a
question in the chat.
I I had many questions during the
presentation.
Um
so just on those experiments at the end,
what kind of software did you use and
how much or what kind of different
adaptation was required between the
different settings?
>> Um so actually you see in the end that
so we have a code repository called like
object RL.
So if you just um take take a screenshot
and uh get to the you know uh
read the QR code, you will be linked
there.
Uh so we mainly used that code
repository. So you'll find all the
details over there.
Honestly, kind of it's not the most
advanced reinforcement learning repo you
would find in the market. So
like implementation of our algorithm is
not super difficult.
Um so it is a standard active critic
pipeline where you have a kind of an
actor network
which is kind of uh
like which has two hidden layers as far
as I remember with 256 something neurons
um fully connected.
Quite similar for uh for the critic.
That's what That's what we needed for
like EvoGym and Dog Run. For the MPC
vision, so there's a convolutional
neural net going behind. The we we have
adopted the same pipeline as the kind of
TRQ V2 which is the state of the art
uh which was the state of the art before
our work I I should say
uh on model three um
um visual control.
But overall uh we are we have like um
middle scale uh single GPU workstations
and there our algorithm works
you know
within 3 hours or so per task.
Does it answer the question?
>> Yeah, how how how much how much kind of
situational crafting does it require to
adapt to these different settings that
have different dimensionality of input
or action selection?
>> So, apart from choosing different
architectures because the, you know,
input dimensionalities are different,
right?
Nothing. So, I I'm not aware of any
hyperparameter one needs to carefully
tune in our algorithm. It's almost like
hyperparameter free. So, apart from I
don't know, learning rate and size
stuff,
uh so, there are no hyperparameters that
uh we didn't need to do any kind of
environment-specific engineering as far
as I know.
>> So, yeah, that's very it's very
interesting. So, what what what
how do you connect
the
dimensionality of the action space
to
Are these all reward-oriented
environments?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Okay. So, it still is linking back
to the single reward signal to close the
loop.
>> Exactly. Yes.
So, the reward comes to play where this
desired state distribution is
determined.
>> Okay.
So, I was curious about the the push
forward contraction lemma
and the infinite horizon modeling. It's
a It's It's a great contribution. So,
I'm very happy that you've presented on
this.
And I'm curious about what kinds of
action spaces this applies to. For
example, what about a multi-agent
setting or an agent that can modify the
niche?
Does that
also have convergence properties to a
fixed point?
Or what about sort of game-theoretic
settings or
open-ended settings?
How do these kinds of fixed point
guarantees for policies relate where
there might be non-stationary
environment or changing rewards or
different kinds of modifications
happening in the environment.
>> So, I don't think it will hold uh if the
MDP is changing in any way.
Uh so, if it is non-stationary for
instance, uh as far as I know, uh there
is no single fixed point uh
in any setting one can think of. So, the
the policy like the optimal policy
becomes history dependent.
So, the same is reflected to our
analysis as well.
Honestly, so I don't know what kind of
implications this uh lemma would have on
uh
on the multi-agent setup. So, I'm not
super fit on uh on the math of
multi-agents. But, I mean, I think it
would be safe for me to say that it
works it surely works on kind of um
sing like first-order Markovian
single-agent systems. Whenever you
change this um no guarantees apply
anymore.
>> Yes. So, it could be totally adequate
still, but it's a different space of
guarantees. Okay, a question in the live
chat is what do you mean by abstract
embeddings?
>> So, it is uh nothing more than for
instance, let's give the example from
here.
If the answer is from pure machine
learning perspective. So, here the task
is to kind of take
this image, this very image which
comprises like raw pixels, pixel
intensities as input.
And map
this image to a control output. So, how
much force torque we should apply to the
joints of this quadruped, right?
So, state abstraction is kind of an
intermediate calculation step from uh
raw input signals
to the controls.
So, it is kind of some
functional mapping from the space of the
raw signals
to
some some abstract kind of
latent real valued manifold.
Yeah, the hope is that so when after
applying this operation, so we will
create some equivalence classes meaning
no matter which state which particular
state we were in the kind of observation
space
the consequence on the actions will be
the same.
>> Okay. Um maybe back to slide 17 there
and I'll read another question from the
live chat.
Okay, Olar Olar wrote
is there an interpretation
for L sub E being close to one? I got
the impression that LE being much less
than one corresponds to large
equivalence classes. Is that right?
>> That's correct. That's correct.
Uh just
you know, this is a kind of qualitative
lemma so to speak. It tells you what
happens if L sub E is
close to zero
but it doesn't tell you when it will be
the case. So or I mean
it is the case when you have like large
equivalence classes but it doesn't tell
you how to get to these like large
equivalence classes to be honest.
>> So cognitively speaking, what would the
large equivalence classes correspond to
and what kinds of situations
are possible into these favorable
equivalence classes?
>> So suppose like you you are seeing the
blackboard
behind me, right?
Suppose I
want to remember something tomorrow and
there is no other
means around me to kind of take notes.
I make a plan. So the plan is to go
there and write something.
So it doesn't really matter
where in this blackboard I write, with
which color I write,
which precise second I write. You know,
they are all kind of details that will
not change the consequence. So, the only
thing I
like the only desired state I want to be
in is that there is something written
over there when I come to the office
tomorrow.
So, it creates a huge equivalence class,
right? So, no matter which way I take
these actions,
this particular action. So, I mean,
writing the you know, a certain note
to any single point over here will end
up with different controls, right? So, I
I I at least need to kind of walk a
little bit to go there, right? So, it
will create different action sequences.
But, the consequence will be the same.
As long as there is a consequence, a
kind of
a later computation step that determines
where I want to reach,
there is kind of an It is very likely
that I will create an equivalence point.
Then, kind of that kind of helps me kind
of make like uh high-level planning.
>> And what is the contraction modulus?
>> Mhm.
Yeah, so it contraction modulus is the
consequence of having like a large
equivalence classes. Yes.
>> How does that play out in terms of the
number of parameters
in the actual model architecture?
>> Mhm.
I don't think there's a one-to-one
relationship. So, you can come up with
like functions with uh you know, high or
low
large or small Lipschitz constant
with
small and large number of parameters.
So,
uh it's it's more about kind of the
the function class rather than how many
parameters it has.
>> And
what classes or what situations
differentiate those classes for the
kinds of like let's just say for a
precision psychiatry modeling setting or
neuroscience setting.
How would someone go from the organism
in the environment
to understanding like what kinds of
classes would be relevant here or what
architectures to even
explore over?
>> [clears throat]
>> It is a bit outside my you know area of
expertise but let me
try my best.
So, one can for instance if one thinks
in terms of these equivalent classes,
one can design maybe like
um experimental
let's say psychological or stimulus
related experiments whatever you call
them where kind of some
like
cognitive processes required for some
kind of a number of steps one needs to
take kind of uh
thinking in terms in like conceptual
terms
and one can for instance test whether
the consequence of this calculation
which ends up with kind of a certain
action
change based on what kind of stimulus I
applied. So, how much my output is
affected by the perturbations on the
input.
The less the perturbation
uh you know the larger the equivalent
class.
But what kind of psychiatrical solutions
we can come up with based on this no
clue honestly.
>> Interesting. That that kind of makes me
think of the
the natural factorization of the senses
like how we we develop a joint
representation of let's say some how
something looks and how it sounds.
However
the
within modality processing
is well factorized in the brain. I'm
thinking of the insect brain, too, where
there's dedicated
olfactory
area
and
uh an integration center that's a bit
clearer than in the mammal brain.
And so that kind of architecturally
enables there to be
equivalence classes across sensory
modalities.
And then they're brought together
in a
reduced representational
setting
after having been
mapped and processed very heavily within
like the visual region or just the
olfactory region.
So I think there's other ways that you
could get to that sort of architecture,
but this
explains it as well.
Um
And I'm also very fascinated at the ends
with the discussion of the measure
theoretic reinforcement learning
complementing or revisiting
what you described as the combinatoric
foundations.
So
what kind of measure theory work
and how does the push forward come into
play?
What would that look like or mean to
have a measure theoretic RL?
>> So
um
for instance,
we I mean, we can just construct an MDP
as um
you know, Markov process and it's push
forward in the way I just mentioned.
And we can just build all the kind of
steps on top of that. For instance, how
shall we do
um policy evaluation?
How shall we do policy improvement on
top of that?
So
um
how shall we prove contractions of
you know, any reinforcement learning
algorithms we will come up with.
So, what I
So, it's an active research we are doing
nowadays and
hopefully you will kind of get a you
will see a preprint in a couple of
months
ideally like before the NIPS deadline. I
don't want to give promises but that's
our goal at least.
So, that are kind of you will see it's
kind of the first draft. So,
uh how far can we go without really
building a table of
Q-values?
So, that's kind of the challenge we are
taking. So, we are not allowed to do
Q-learning anymore. So, we need to live
it like fitted Q-iteration for instance.
Because we cannot kind of put kind of
all the all possibilities kind of into a
table kind of and start working on
matrices anymore.
Right? So, um
then we
So, we are in a space where we don't
know how many states there are and how
many actions there are. Whether they are
continuous or discrete, we even don't
know that. Right?
So, it kind of
brings about certain limitations that
are quite interesting to study. But, the
nice thing is so
what our earlier results are showing us
is that
any solution you find directly
generalizes to kind of all active critic
architectures you have currently.
So, that's what the
what the main purpose of that track is.
Um but, it's still work in progress. So,
if I have bigger news I will I promise I
will tell you.
>> Okay. Okay. What what I heard there is
if we start in a sort of discrete
combinatoric setting with a tabular data
format, whether we're looking at
observation reward mapping or Q-learning
state transition reward type learning,
we're still in this discretized setting,
where
it's at least amenable, if not
um tractable, to doing combinatoric
resampling-based approaches and other
methods. Whereas, if we want to
escape the matrix
and generalize into a potentially
continuous
state space for
sensory, internal, action, external
states,
we're in a
measure-theoretic or
information-geometric
setting
where there's much more of an emphasis
on manifold properties, continuity, and
other analytic features of the cognitive
setting, uh which may interpolate
and be downsampled into a discretized
combinatoric amenable
equivalence relationship, but this is a
much smoother and more performance
method, where we could use like
derivatives and integrals and a variety
of other tools.
>> Exactly.
But, the problem is as follows. So,
up front, like from the very beginning,
we assume that the state state and
action space is discrete.
And then we build a system on top of
that. And then we find
a continuous counterpart of it. So,
that's That's the common practice in
reinforcement learning nowadays.
And uh you see that kind of certain
things you expect to work
are actually not working. There is a
kind of notion appearing like an
overestimation bias, for instance. So, I
wouldn't expect that to happen in a kind
of discrete MDP, for instance.
Uh then one gets surprised. Uh so, our
hypothesis here is that kind of these
are symptoms of
starting from
a discrete realm,
doing all the like developing all the
essential elements of the theory on the
discrete realm and then projecting
the solutions to the continuous realm.
Instead, let's start from the you know
with without making any assumptions
about whether we are in a discrete or
continuous realm, we have major
theoretic elements. That's it.
And let's see how far we can get without
assuming anything about the functional
approximator, optimizer, anything.
Whatever we can say, our goal is to say
that and then take from there and
develop like practical algorithms
afterwards.
>> Yeah, that's a very nice direction. It
also reminds me of the continuous in the
discrete state space distinction even
like in the 2022 active inference
textbook in the way that the
combinatoric versus measure theoretic
approach to action planning where it's
like in the discrete time, we have
tree-based rollouts
and everything that's come along with
that and you know tree pruning, all
that. Whereas in the continuous time
there's more of a Taylor series
expansion and a generalized coordinates
of motion approach. So on one hand, you
get kind of hypothetically infinite
horizon Taylor series expansion but then
it becomes very difficult to understand
how adequate your approximation is
and you don't exactly get
counterfactuals in the same way as the
explicit
tree-based policy rollout methods.
And in the textbook, they're kind of
just held up side by side and I think
this work is making some very important
steps to
unify
that.
>> Agreed.
>> Okay, if you have any other
please feel free. Otherwise, this was
awesome and it's very exciting to hear
about the research.
>> Nothing to add on my end.
Thanks very much for inviting. I
entertained. So, I it was very
entertaining for me kind of both to
prepare and to give the presentation and
have this very nice dialogue with you.
>> Thank you. Good luck with you and your
lab. Bye.
>> Thanks. Bye-bye.